Mr Speaker the public rightly expect us
to control our borders whether that is
stopping the boats and addressing
illegal migration or whether it's
ensuring levels of legal migration do
not Place undue pressure on public
services on housing Supply or
integration the government is taking
decisive action on both counts
under the points-based system we
introduced post brexit we can control
immigration we must control immigration
and we will
Shadow Home Secretary ofek
Mr Speaker today's extraordinary figures
including doubling the number of work
visas since the pandemic show that the
conservatives have no plan and no grip
on immigration they show the chaos in
this government work visas are 119 since
before the pandemic conservatives have
totally failed to tackle endemic skills
shortages and get people back to work
net migration is more than twice the
level that ministers were aiming for and
considerably more than that compared to
the home secretaries claimed aims the
Asylum backlog is at a record high the
opposite of the prime minister's promise
to clear the backlog this year and less
than one percent of last year's small
boat arrivals have had a decision yet
where is the Home Secretary who is in
charge of these policies she's gone to
ground there are reports she's not even
going to do media she's not come to this
house she's in internal media things
presumably more private courses arranged
by the civil servants what is the point
of her net migration should come down
and we would expect it to do so but the
continued gap between the government's
reality and the government's rhetoric
and the reality is very damaging rightly
the UK has given support to Ukraine and
Hong Kong as rightly we welcome
International students who bring
substantial benefits but changes on
family are sensible International
recruitment will also always be
important so we get the skills and
talent we need but this is a major
increase in employers turning to
overseas Recruitment and the government
has no plan to increase training or
properly tackle those skill shortages
from here at home so on Health and
Social care one of the biggest areas why
will he not agree to Labor's plan to
increase the training for nurses and
doctors in the UK paid for by getting
rid of the non-doms exemption will he
ditch the unfair 20 wage discount that
means shortage occupations can actually
undercut and pay below the going rate
making it even harder to get to the
training and the skills and the fair
recruitment that we need everyone should
be paid the going rate Mr W speakers Mr
Mr Speaker there has been no action at
all to address the huge backlog in the
Asylum system and to make sure that as
claims are properly processed
we need immigration is important to this
country and we need a system that works
but it has to be properly controlled and
managed rather than the chaos that the
government has created
well thank you uh Mr Speaker the labor
party feigns interest in cutting net
migration but I can assure the right
honorable lady that nobody is buying it
last week the chair of the labor party
said that under labor net migration
would go up in the short term the leader
of the labor party stood on a campaign
pledge to defend freedom of movement if
the UK remained outside of the EU he
said that there is a racist undercurrent
which permeates all immigration laws
does the home the shadow Home Secretary
agree with them at every possible
opportunity labor have voted against
every measure that this government has
brought forward to control migration
they vote they voted against ending free
movement and at every turn they voted
against measures to tackle illegal
migration like just recently they voted
against the illegal migration bill
because the truth is Mr Speaker the
labor party have no interest in
controlled and orderly migration the
conservative party is taking tangible
steps to bring down net migration
yesterday we took a decisive step to
clamp down on student dependence because
universities should be selling education
not immigration belatedly the shadow
Home Secretary says she agrees with that
Mr Speaker the conservative party made a
solemn promise to the British public to
reduce net migration
rights to brexit we now have the tools
at our disposal to do that we can and we
must deliver
the house of Peter bottom
can I say to my original friend I'm
sorry that while he's replying to the
questions four of the front benches were
talking at the same time I think that
was to disguise the fact that their
speaker appeared to agree with virtually
every sensible element of the
government's immigration and control
policy
I can I ask my random friend if you'll
agree with me that if you go to beyond
the emission order office there's the
memorial plaque for the Kinder transport
some of those who feel most strongly
against immigration now I feel proud of
what we did then we have to remember
that then and now there are tens of
millions of people around the world
suffering because of balance in their
own countries others who have bad
governments that stop them allowing to
have economic success where they are as
well as a good immigration policy can I
say that we ought to do all we can to
help around the world better governance
and the flexible economic system so that
people could be happy living where they
are and not feeling they have to come
here for Refuge
well can I strongly agree with the
father of the house we've made two very
significant interventions in the last
two years one to provide Sanctuary here
in the United Kingdom for those Hong
Kong bnos who we have a moral and
historical obligation to to escape
creeping authoritarianism in Hong Kong
and make a new life here in the UK we
should be proud of that and I expect in
the years to come that scheme will be
looked back on as a great success for
this country and secondly the Hong Kong
the Ukraine schemes which have led now
to 200 000 ukrainians coming to the UK
seeking Sanctuary here
hundreds of thousands of British people
literally opening up their homes to
support them those were great schemes we
want to ensure schemes like that can
continue and that the UK can be an even
greater force for good in the world
that does not however mean that we
should uh go slow on further measures to
bring down net migration because net
migration does Place very significant
burdens upon communities in terms of
Housing and public services and our
ability to integrate people that's why
we made further interventions this week
and we'll consider further ones in the
future as some police spokesperson
Stuart Sue McDonald thank you Mr Speaker
and can I start by recognizing the
amazing contribution of all laws who
have come to make the UK their home
whether they are refugees or students
care workers nurses Hospitality workers
or anything else and on these benches we
say thank you and of course it was right
to welcome opinions and bnos from Hong
Kong in 2022 and we welcome that as well
and I really hope that British politics
isn't going to descend back into a
horrible competition about who is going
to be toughest on immigration Mr Speaker
ministers often give us a nice sound
about how they want the migration system
that works for the whole of the UK we
say fine but that doesn't mean basically
the same policies need to apply
absolutely everywhere in Scotland we
have no need or desire for policies that
are going to put international students
off keep families apart or make it
harder to recruit the workers that we
need so does he manage to have anything
to say about the unique challenges faced
by different parts of the UK and how
that shapes immigration policy and we'll
even just look again at the remote areas
pilot scheme recommended by the
migration advisory committee and sought
and voted for by the Scottish Parliament
Minister well I wasn't expecting a
question today arguing that net
migration was too low that seems to be
the position of the the SMP but he makes
a fair point that we need to take a
pragmatic approach to particular sectors
which are facing uh skill shortages and
also to think about the uh the regional
disparities across the whole of the
United Kingdom we don't believe that
there should be separate immigration
systems for the nations of the UK and we
don't believe that the evidence bears
that out there isn't a material
difference in either unemployment or in
economic inactivity between Scotland and
the United Kingdom average we do take
account through the shortage occupation
list of particular sectors that are
facing challenges and some of those are
of course more focused in parts of the
UK than others earlier in the week for
example we made the decision to add
further phishing occupations to the
shortage occupation list to support the
offshore fishing industry which I hope
he and and fellow Scottish members of
parliament that have connections with
the fishing industry will support
sir edwardly
some people in the treasury seem to
think that a good way to grow the
economy is to fill the country up with
more and more people
but this is bad for productivity and bad
for British workers who are being
undercut by mass migration from all over
the world
why is it that under the points-based
system we allow people in earning only
26 000 a year but the median UK salary
is 33 000 a year is it an obvious
solution to this to insist that
everybody comes in is skilled and earns
a median UK salary and then we can boost
product if we didn't get British people
back to work minister
well my right normal friend makes uh an
important Point that he's made in in the
past and one which I have a lot of
sympathy with we both believe that we
need a controlled migration system and
that net migration has a number of
impacts upon communities including
further pressure on public services
further pressure on housing Supply and
making it more difficult to integrate
people into our country and maintain
Community cohesion in some instances
high levels of net migration also Place
pressure downward on wages for the
domestic economy and enable some
employers to reach for the easy lever of
importing foreign labor rather than
training up their own British Workforce
it's for those reasons that we created
the points-based system that has a
salary threshold a freedom that we only
have as a result of leaving the European
Union and if there are further changes
to that system uh necessary in the
future we'll take them
thank you very much I did Mr Speaker
well local resident my constituency are
quite rightly shocked and concerned to
here the ministers department is
planning to house 300 Asylum seekers in
the Australia Park Hotel a totally
disproportionate number for the village
of furnace and local services so will
the minister agree to meet with me to
hear about local concerns and what is he
doing to prevent the need to commandeer
the straddy Park Hotel and to clear the
home office backlog of 160 000
undetermined claims so those from safe
countries can be returned and those who
are genuine refugees who move out of
hotels and be integrated in small
numbers into suitable communities well
I'm delighted to hear that the
government has chalked up another vote
for the illegal migration bill because
you cannot have a position where you say
you want open borders unlimited numbers
of individuals coming into this country
where the legally or legally but you
don't want them in your own constituency
that is an inconsistent approach if the
honorable lady feels so strongly and is
getting such strong representations from
her constituents she should support the
government's efforts to clamp down on
illegal migration sir Desmond sway
when they take effect
what estimate has he got for the impact
of the measures they had announced
yesterday
well we believe that the measures we
announced yesterday with regard to
student dependence will have a tangible
effect on the number of student
defendants coming into the country which
is the figures published by the ons show
are very considerable today it isn't
right that universities in some cases
are in the immigration business rather
than uh the teaching and education one
we're clamping down on those practices
and that will help us to bring down net
migration in the medium term but I mean
let me be abundantly clear to my our
Channel friend net migration is far too
high and we need to take measures to
bring it down we are not complacent we
want to make good on our promise to the
British public
because immigration Minister seems to be
making a very good case for increased
wage inflation I wonder what his
colleagues in treasury make of that
about the overall impact on the economy
sector after sector whether it's
agriculture a Hospitality fishing care
services all tell us that they need
access to more skilled staff and that
they simply do not have that access at
the moment the minister stands at the
dispatch box and talks about adding
fishing to the shortage occupation list
but he completely ignores the fact that
his refusal in the home secretary's
refusal to lower the standard of English
language skills that are required
renders that absolutely meaningless for
the fishing industry as a result of his
decision fishing boats in my
constituency and right around the coast
are tied up today when is he going to
start listening to business and when did
the conservative party stop doing that
well the case that I was making was that
you sustainably increase productivity by
encouraging our employers to invest in
their Workforce and in technology rather
than simply reaching for the easy lever
of further International labor with
respect to the fishing sector we've made
this measure today and it's been broadly
welcomed or this weekend it's been
broadly welcomed by the fishing sector I
fundamentally disagree I fundamentally
disagree with the right honorable
gentleman if his contention is that we
should allow people into the United
Kingdom on visas that have a route to
settlement who cannot speak or write
English
that is wrong the standard of English
that we maintain is a low standard and
we need it for health and safety at the
workplace to prevent exploitation and to
ensure people can integrate into our
communities that is absolutely the right
approach
people who come to this country and want
to work in our country and add value to
our country are welcome and clearly the
concern is the illegal migration figures
that have continued to grow
football given the figures have almost
flatlined in terms of net migration can
my honor right on a friend lay up for us
what has happened over that period of
time and what his plans are for the
future to make sure that that total
measure comes down
well the the ons have changed its
methodology uh and have increased the
estimate that they made in the middle of
last year to say that the uh number for
net migration was 606 000 at that point
when they previously published their
data and that since then they see no
evidence that it's increased which
suggests that numbers are now flatlining
there are reasons to believe that the
number of individuals coming on our
humanitarian schemes from Hong Kong and
Ukraine will reduce over the course of
this year although it's difficult to
predict with any certainty particularly
with respect to Ukraine the measures
that we've taken this week with respect
to student dependence will have a
material impact and so it's reasonable
to assume that numbers will now be on a
downward trajectory but I don't want to
give any impression of complacency
there's clearly great deal more to be
done and if we need to take further
interventions we will do
live effort
speaker the government's clearly lost
control of all aspects of immigration
and migration and
we have hope voted against the
nationality and borders bill and the
illegal immigration bill because we said
they wouldn't work and these figures
show they haven't worked yeah so can you
can you explain why it is that fewer
than one percent of the people who
arrive on small boats last year have
actually had their Asylum claims
determined and why is the figure so low
well the The Honorable gentleman has
voted against or his party have voted
against every measure that this
government has brought forward to
control migration whether that be legal
or migrate or illegal so his contention
that the labor party would get control
of uh migration is is frankly laughable
but it is important that we bring the
backlog of cases down that's why the
Prime Minister home sector and I have
set out a very clear plan to do that
we're seeing the dividends of that and
we expect the Legacy backlog to be
cleared over the course of the year as
we promised it is not correct however to
suggest that if you can process illegal
migrants claims faster that will reduce
the number of people coming into the
country in all likelihood it will lead
to an increase well Tim Victor thank you
Mr Speaker
the the anger and frustration of my uh
constituents has been focused on illegal
migration up until now but that anger
and frustration will grow when they
consider these legal migration figures
we're creating roughly speaking eight
new parliamentary constituencies with
this number and if that continues it's
clearly unsustainable the minister spoke
about medium-term uh plans to reduce the
numbers but what mark constituents want
to know is what short-term plans there
are other than those that is have been
announced recently what else is in the
department considering well said well my
honored friend makes a number of
important points and I think few members
of this house have argued more
consistently than I have that we need to
build more homes in this country and
there needs to be a proper join up
between the numbers coming in and the
way we accommodate them there are I'm
afraid intolerable pressures placed upon
the country's public services and
housing Supply by sustained very high
levels of net migration and that's one
of the reasons why we need to take
action we have announced a package of
measures uh this week which include
changes to the rules with respect to
student dependence and increased
enforcement activity as well to clamp
down on egregious abuse of the system by
education agents as I said in answer
early questions if there are more
changes we need to make we will do so
nixman
there's a huge gap between the
government's rhetoric and reality the
minister just said that the net
migration figure would return to
pre-pandemic levels in the medium terms
so can you please say what his
assessment is for the net migration
figure for the year ahead
well as I said in answer to earlier
questions we expect numbers uh to reduce
uh we're taking further steps this week
which we think will make a material
difference and if we need to do more we
will do because net migration is far too
high I hope that the honorable Gentleman
by his question agrees with me uh in
that regard and that he will support
measures that we take to bring the
numbers down
helps you Mr Speaker
if it were possible
for everyone illegal that crossed the
channel in a small boat to be returned
to France
that would be not only in our interest
but also in the interest of France
because it would stop people buffering
on the Northeast Coast to try and get
into this country I know it's very
difficult
but what chances are that being able to
happen because it would solve the
problem
we're making considerable efforts to
deepen our relationship with the French
government in fact next week I'm in
Paris meeting our counterparts in the
French interior Ministry the Prime
Minister has achieved in short
succession to significant deals which
are leading to an increase in activity
on the beaches increased joint working
on counter organized immigration crime
and a new joint working Center in Lille
that I'll be visiting shortly if there
was a possibility of a of a readmissions
agreement with France that's suddenly
something that the government would
welcome we've made that clear and in our
conversations both with president macron
and with uh the commission president uh
Sila Von delayan we have offered a range
of solutions that could lead to that I
would just say however that the previous
readmissions agreement Dublin that
operated during our time in the European
Union was not a successful one uh in the
last years of its operation in fact more
people were being brought from France to
the United Kingdom than sent from the UK
to France so this isn't a Panacea but if
there are ways in which we contains
forward we will do I don't care
Mr Speaker the
two Arise at net migration is something
to fear let's get it be further from the
truth immigrants across all four nations
make contribution to society politically
economically and socially from running
small local businesses in our high
streets to developing groundbreaking
technology and working in the NHS
they're integral to society Mr Speaker
in my maiden speech I called for
immigration to be devolved Scotland
wants immigration and our needs are
different does the minister agree that
now is the time for immigration to be
devolved to the Scottish Parliament
well I don't agree with the honorable
lady as I've already said in answer to
other questions there there is a limit
to the number of individuals who can
come into any country uh regardless of
the benefits that they might bring
because we have finite resources in
terms of Housing and access to public
services independent advisors including
the migration advisory committee have
said that there are a range of reasons
uh why migrants choose to come to other
parts of the UK over Scotland in some
cases and there is a role for the
Scottish government in tackling those
issues will be French thank you Mr
Speaker unsustainable levels of
migration continue to have a significant
impact on the likes of housing in the
Southeast does my honorable friend agree
that we must do all we can to reach
sustainable levels of migration and when
it comes to Illegal migration and
processing Asylum claims ensure that the
home office cracks down on both the
people's Smugglers whilst also ensuring
the likes of Scotland takes its fair
share of people rather than just
continuing to turn up here on virtue
signal yeah yeah well I I strongly agree
with my honorable friend it's critical
that we take action to bring down net
migration he represents one of the
communities where there is intense
pressure on housing and it's a struggle
for many young people and those on low
incomes to get on the housing ladder we
have to be cognizant of that when
setting our migration policies he's
absolutely right with respect to the SMP
they are I'm afraid humanitarian nimbers
they come here and preach but their
actions never meet up with their uh or
their their words are always greater
than their actions Karen Smith
dispatch box which is that
um the home of his inability to progress
applications resulting in many people
living in hotels including in in Bristol
and across the country means that the
holding pattern will remain for some
time
um and that may be in fact a deliberate
policy and as a minister said if they
were progressed there would be there
would be more that is what he has said
he can clarify so the the question is
really how long are hotels people
expected to live in hotels in cities
across the country what is the support
being given to local authorities as well
and friends with Leslie just asked and
what is the ultimate plan that the
government has for these people
yeah I didn't say that and The Honorable
lady should uh check the record after
this urgent question what I said was
that the the labor party's approach as I
understand it is to let more people in
and to process their claims faster and I
gently pointed out that that is very
unlikely to result in fewer illegal
migrate migrants crossing the channel
what we do need to do is suffuse our
entire system with deterrence that's why
we're bringing forward new sites like
the large sites and barges that's why we
bring forward the illegal migration Bill
we want to clear the backlog but above
all we want to stop people coming in the
first place and the sustainable answer
to that is break the business model of
the people Smugglers back the illegal
migration Bill Aaron Bell thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker today's figures are
too high and my constituents in
Newcastle underlying will expect to see
them fall so can I welcome up the office
of national statistics have said about
them flatlining and can I also again
welcome what he announced yesterday
about Stu dependent visas which I think
will help them to fall does he agree
with me that my constituents will not be
buying the line from the opposition Home
Secretary because the opposition are led
by an arch remainer who favors freedom
of movement and have voted against every
single measure we have brought to
control migration both legal and illegal
including our bill to stop the votes
well my honor friend is absolutely right
I think nobody believes the position of
the labor party because time and again
when they're offered the opportunity to
vote for legislation they would tighten
control on migration whether that be
legal or illegal they always vote
against it we all know that our borders
would be open under a future labor
government that's why we need to take
the steps that we have and that's why
your constituents should continue to
back you in the conservative party
remember
the in fact the number of people waiting
for their Asylum applications to be
processed for longer than six months has
risen we've had the figures today it's
risen by ten thousand to a hundred and
twenty eight thousand the minister has
suggested that reducing the backlog
which is a government objective won't
make any difference can he tell us
whether he does want to reduce the
backlog whether he thinks that reducing
the backlog won't make any difference
and on what basis he is now making that
assessment good question well I've been
very clear that we want to reduce the
backlog that's part of our 10-point plan
to tackle illegal migration we've put in
place a series of measures to reduce
bureaucracy to streamline the process to
double the number of Asylum decision
makers and those uh Investments are
already paying dividends uh there is
we're confident that the Legacy backlog
will be cleared over the course of the
year the point that I was making I'm
happy to to reiterate is that the faster
the process the more pull factor there
is to the United Kingdom that isn't a
reason to maintain an info patient
process but what we do need to have is a
process where deterrence is suffused
through every element or else we will
never break the business model of the
people Smugglers pigeon you speak at my
old home state of Western Australia has
just announced even further investment
in additional support for international
students saying it is important we
provide such students with a safe and
welcoming environment for them to
flourish in the education is a global
market so can you explain why it's a
good thing International students will
simply take their money skills and
enthusiasm elsewhere deterred by this
Crackdown on their families and the
support they offer rather than choose
the UK where life for them is made ever
more difficult
presume The Honorable lady will welcome
the fact that the government's
International Education strategy which
set a target of 600 000 International
students coming to the UK every year has
been met 10 years early and last year
000 International students came and I
suspect the number this year uh will be
higher than that still so there's
absolutely no uh sense that the
government is renaving on those
commitments or creating the environment
that is unwelcoming to International
students what we do want to see is
universities focusing on teaching and
not an inadvertently creating a backdoor
to immigration status here in the UK
that's why we've made the changes that
we have this week which have been
broadly welcomed both by the public and
by the sector
thank you very much Mr Speaker the the
office for National statistics has this
morning published the record net
migration figure of 606 000 which by the
way includes 114 000 long-term arrivals
from Ukraine and 52 000 for from Hong
Kong so well below 170 000 in total we
all remember the previous conservative
prime minister falsely promising to the
British people that he would bring net
migration down to the tens of thousands
and the last but one prime minister
promising that he would bring uh net
migration figures to below 250 000 but
he also failed miserably I won't even
mention the last prime minister because
she didn't even last for two months
before crashing the economy but uh
Minister the last conservative party
Manifesto pledged and and I quote that
overall net migration numbers would come
down so how's that going what went wrong
yeah well
well we wouldn't have the tools to
tackle net migration had we taken the
honorable gentleman's advice and
remained within the European Union it's
only as a result of the new freedoms
that we have that we can control our
immigration system and he has voted
against every possible opportunity to
tackle either legal or illegal migration
so I'm afraid he's got he has no uh you
know foot to stand on on this argument
Martin Docker to yours thank you Mr
Speaker interviewing the net migration
numbers I wonder if the minister has
also had time to review the number of
missing unaccompanied migrant children
in the United Kingdom which at last year
was over 200 and if he's not had time to
review that could he maybe come back to
the house and tell us how many of those
missing children have been found and
what is governments doing to make sure
it never happens again
well I have looked at this issue in
great detail and have spent time with
our own officials in the home office
with the local authorities where we have
U.S hotels
speaking privately to the social workers
and support staff that care for them to
ensure that we have the right processes
in place and I'm confident that we do
the hotels have a range of support
around them very considerable support
and when an individual a young person
goes missing from those hotels all of
the same processes are followed as any
other missing person whether that be a
child of a migrant or our own children
a liquor store
thank you Secretary of State rates very
important questions about work visas and
I don't think The Minister's quite
addressed yet those work visas has
doubled since the pandemic is the
government satisfied with that increase
good question well we want to have a
system that enables businesses to bring
foreign workers in where there are
sustained skilled shortages but we want
British employers to focus in the first
instance on training British workers to
fill those vacancies because there are
large numbers of people who are
economically inactive and the first duty
of employers and of the government is to
help those people back into the
workforce
Mr Speaker immigrants make an invaluable
contribution to our economy they enrich
our communities and international
students in particular are needed and
valued especially in this post-brexit
labor shortage era uh and yet the
reactionary and hostile plans that this
government are determined to put into
place and his tone in the chamber today
I think speak very clearly of a desire
to impede our ability to make the right
arrangements for Scotland
um does he recognize how it shouldn't
his government is with the views of
people in Scotland and with the needs of
the Scottish economy and does he not
appreciate why it is absolutely
essential that we do have the power to
make the right immigration arrangements
for Scotland in order that our economy
can Thrive well The Honorable ladies
argument is not one that's borne out by
any available evidence there's no
material difference between unemployment
in Scotland or economic inactivity in
Scotland and out in the rest of the
United Kingdom and the reports produced
by the migration advisory committee
raise a number of questions for the
Scottish government as the policies that
it could put in place to make Scotland a
more attractive destination for migrants
or indeed workers from elsewhere within
the United Kingdom
speaker there are now 172
758 people in the growing Asylum backlog
I've met Asylum seekers in my
constituency have been housed for well
over a year in overcrowded hotel rooms
many with small children who have
nowhere to play will the government
finally admit that their illegal illegal
migration bill will make that backlog
and their traumatic weight worse not
better
well The Honorable lady is absolutely
wrong about that because the illegal
migration Bill creates a fast and simple
scheme whereby those who come here
illegally on small boats or otherwise
will not have their claims processed in
months or years but in days and weeks
and will either be returned home to a
safe country like Albania autra safe
Third Country like Rwanda that will
break the business model of the people
Smugglers by infusing the system with
deterrence and see a very substantial
reduction in the numbers entering the
country in this manner
thank you speaker in both the
hospitality sector is a big Drive of our
local economy yet many of our wonderful
hotels restaurants bars pubs struggle to
find enough staff and the danger is
closure or reduced working hours which
is bad for the economy the government's
chaotic approach of headline grabbing
and breaking and making immigration
targets have completely eroded public
trust including those of employers when
will the government come clean with the
public and acknowledge that legal
migration is driven by the labor market
and listen to employers like those in
the hospitality sector
well I think the honorable lady is
arguing for significantly higher levels
of legal migration than those we have
today I'd point out that there were 235
000 work-related visas issued last year
these are very substantial numbers I
don't think it's wise to advocate for a
significant further increase we want to
see these numbers coming down
speaker The Minister's already accepted
we need immigration in this country for
skills gaps now over the last 15 years
we've heard a number of fake promises
about bringing immigration down reducing
as my honorable friend reminded Us by
the redcon members that reminded us that
the previous Prime Minister David
Cameron want to bring down to tens of
thousands the has not clearly not been
achieved now I say this to the minister
not to score political points but what
does he believe is the right amount of
migration to this country and does it
have a specific figure and is this
achievable in the next decade
well we've made a very clear Manifesto
commitment which is to see numbers
falling sustainably we're taking action
this week which will have a material
impact but as I said a number of times
this morning that net migration is far
too high and I worry that that is
placing intolerable pressure on public
services on housing Supply and on our
ability as a country to integrate new
arrivals those are the reasons why we
need to take action if we need to take
further steps we will do
I think the minister needs to get his
story straight on the Asylum backlog is
he saying that he wants to get it down
in which case he's not doing a very good
job because it's up to 172 000 or is he
saying he's keeping it high with all the
attendant costs the misery of that in
order to deter fresh claims
I've been very clear that we want to get
the backlog in cases down but what I've
also pointed out is that Labor's only
policy with respect to Illegal migration
is to clear the backlog faster
open borders faster processing that's
not going to work
thank you Mr Speaker the minister and I
have clearly never going to agree on
whether or not immigration is too high
but one area where we might be able to
agree that it's too low it's when it
comes to the uh rural areas and the need
to for seasonal workers in the aggregate
sector where a shortage of such workers
left millions of pounds of fresh produce
to rot in the fields now the Scottish
government has called for a bespoke
rural Visa scheme to help bring that
labor that is needed to Scotland to help
pick that would the minister agree to
meet with me so that we can tease out
some of the issues around that maybe
free from the pressures to generate
headlines in tomorrow's press well I'll
be happy to discuss that that issue with
him in the spirit that he he raised it
today I'm not persuaded that it's
practical to create an immigration
system whereby we have visas specific to
certain parts of the United Kingdom or
to rural versus urban areas we do have a
seasonal agricultural workers scheme
we've recently announced that will
continue next year and in fact we've
offered to increase it to 55 000 people
per year last year the scheme was capped
at 45 000 and we had fewer applications
than that number so it seems to be
operating at the correct level we do
have to be very careful about abuse and
we did see last year I'm afraid a rise
in the number of people who came across
on the scheme who are either exploited
by gang Masters or who put in Asylum
claims and it wouldn't be right for us
to create a system that lead to a
further increase in either of those
activities
Mr Speaker
um the minister will know that I believe
very much that we have a moral
obligation uh to help the widows the
children and the orphans and that is why
I believe we must have a robust
emigration and Asylum system that allows
the vulnerable and the needy to find
their new home I can sit in their mind
um has a hard working your man who
you're seeking to bring his brother and
daughter to the UK to Northern Ireland
and to 19 of Newton Arch by the way
they lost they lost his brother who lost
all of their entire family in the
Turkish earthquake
and yet we have an end pass which I've
been finding quite frustrating Mr
Speaker can the minister on the line
what changes can be made to prevent an
influx of on my young men to be allowed
instead of a focus on those devastated
children lone parents and their families
well I'd be happy to look at the
honorable gentleman's specific case if
if he wishes with respect to dependence
of migrants coming into the UK we do
have schemes and the numbers published
by the ons Today Show that there are
significant numbers of my of migrants
dependents entering the country or the
family members of British citizens uh
with respect to the broader point which
he regularly Champions about the UK
being a Force for good in the world and
welcoming people for humanitarian
purposes the numbers published Today
Show that the UK is one of the world's
leading countries for humanitarian Visa
routes we should be proud of that and
not accept anybody who says otherwise
that completes the Urgent question those
who wish to leave please do so
okay
right we come to the business center can
I call Shadow leave the house
thank you Mr Speaker to ask the leader
of the house that she will give us the
forthcoming business
before I give the business the house Mr
Speaker I'll just like to make a brief
statement first of all I want to
associate myself with the remarks made
in this